okay thanks all for being here and
getting some energy to start the day I
um I woke up in beautiful Cambridge
Massachusetts this morning and I rode a
bike across Cambridge at 4am to make the
first to sell of the day get down here
and I'm very excited
uh so the The Talk today is on Jacks for
days
um I'm gonna be talking a little bit
uh about doing Bayesian analysis Basin
probability
um
in Jacks and generally giving an outline
of what the whole ecosystem looks like
um I don't know has anyone heard the
term force staff I don't know if this is
just like our family thing like you go
out to the forest and you're you're just
there being in nature and you're
enjoying it getting a feel for things
um so today's gonna be like a code back
um so there's gonna be a lot of code
that goes on here and I don't want you
to worry about understanding at all
um it all morally runs it doesn't
actually run uh but there is a a company
in collab that I got all this code from
that actually runs um so I'm not lying
to you when I code Snippets up
uh I'm not I'm not really lying here
sometimes I'm a little bit like you
uh
so the agenda for the day is first to
talk about the daising workflow
um
this is based on uh paper a lot of the
the scan developers also I did have
supported uh project uh papers on the
stand developers I'm working on sort of
a project that they've been doing a lot
of really interesting discussions around
um and then second I want to talk about
how uh how the Jax ecosystem can feed
into the gazing workflow
um and and hopefully
hopefully you all will take away from
this talk either a structured way to
think about it
and or some useful libraries to try out
in the future and some ways to think
about how
uh how the open source world might might
approach based in computation in the
future
so that's a lot of big words
um that's a very high look like I said
there's going to be a lot of a lot of
code going on
um so first of all the this is the
Bayesian workflow from this uh Gilman
adult paper I encourage you to go look
for uh for the paper you can just Google
Bayesian workflow Gilman
um
the word is that they will not be able
to get this published but they might
just turn into a book because it's it's
wonderful things
um so I sort of recreated the uh the
workflow that they have up here and I
thought a good way you know these are a
lot of steps there's a lot of places to
go and I thought a good way is just to
work through a case study and we'll just
highlight what steps we're at um for
for each of these
uh the case study I'm going to work
through is a golfing one
um possibly people know about golfing uh
you're you're hitting a tiny ball around
a big green space that might be better
served as forest and eventually you get
it onto a even finer mode section called
the green and you try to put it in with
a much smaller Club than you had been
using the rest of the day so this is a
very small data set it's got distance
which I think is in feet it's got the
number of observations we have of people
trying to putt from that distance and
then a number of successes
uh it might be easier just to visualize
it
uh and so you can see like from from two
feet away people usually make the putt
um these are I believe professional
golfers
um so they're better than perhaps URI
um and from like 20 feet away it's it's
much rarer to make a putt um from there
and and maybe we're giving this uh data
set and we want to build a model
so how do we do that we might turn to
our Bayesian uh Bayesian Library so I'm
I'm using tensorflow probability
um that's a library that I do help
develop it's called tensorflow
probability we've talked about trying to
Rebrand as tensor friendly probability
because it actually works on Jax
um so if you use this import statement
tensorflow
probability.substrates.jacks you get a
version that's uh that everything is
written in Jax
um Jack's tools work nicely with
and this is how you write a model in
tensorflow probability a lot of
probabilistic programming languages look
fairly similar to this I'll show a bunch
other languages later
but the things I want to highlight is
that your random variables can be used
just like your normal programming
variables so we Define this slope here
as being a normal normally distributed
random variable same as intercept and
then later on we can plug those in and
use them multiply them by other numbers
uh the model we're doing here for those
of you who's uh
who's like
used a probabilistic programming
language before you can get perfect
perfect so for those of you who have not
used a program probabilistic programming
language before you might be looking and
wondering for example why am I choosing
like
these distributions normals and
binomials uh the easy answer is that
normal is a safe choice if you have
nothing better to do you might choose a
normal binomial just turns out to be the
right choice for a problem like this a
binomial distribution describes how many
successes you'll get in
total count tries given well this is the
legit of a probability but given some
probability of success some number of
tries the distribution of successes is
given by a binomial distribution so this
just turns out to be like you know we
give we give special names to special
distributions this is the special
distribution for situations like this
and so what we're trying to do with this
model essentially is fit uh fit a line
you know slope and intercept slope times
the distance plus some intercept
um we'll call it a two parameter model
because we want to learn about the slope
and The Intercept the successes we'll
actually condition on we'll say hey we
actually saw this number of successes
um but we'll do that later
so this is initializing the model so I
wrote down the model and you'll also see
that there's a decorator up there I feel
like every python conference has a
little talk about decorators they're
hard to get your mind around but they
eat functions and give you back new
functions and the thing that this gives
you back is actually a class and it has
two methods that are important to us
today one is called sample and one is
called log probability
and so you can take this regression
model object and call sample on it and
it'll give you samples from these
parameters you can also pass values for
those parameters back in and it'll
compute the log probability of those
um
the other thing I should say is the
reason it's a log probability not a
probability is because probabilities get
very very tiny so log probabilities are
better for computers to use
how are we feeling so far
very good don't don't have to understand
everything you know we're letting it
wash over us we'll see a lot of code
uh so we've done we've initialized a
model we got a prior predictive check
now and we can use our model to help out
with our prior predictive Checker power
predictive check is let's just make sure
our priors are reasonable so for those
of us who haven't done basic modeling or
those who have sometimes it's hard to
know what model you just wrote down and
it's useful to sample from your model
um so I'm calling that sample I'm
Computing the probability something goes
in by you see that those draws have a
DOT slope and a DOT intercept method
um so I can just pass those into a logit
which is confusingly expedit over here
um and then I get a probability that
everything goes in
sorry expert is the inverse of the logit
good
terrible this is recorded everyone
um so what do I get I get all these
lines
um so this was a hundred draws from the
prior
um the prior knows nothing about our
actual data I've plotted our data here
just for interest sake but here are 100
places where a model thinks our
reasonable for uh to predict at the end
of the day I highlighted one in Orange
because that looked the most reasonable
to me it took me a while to find it
um and if I was like being really
careful I might look at this and say hey
there are a bunch of lines with a
positive slope I like actually think
that's really unlikely that golfers get
better at putting as they get farther
away from the hole so maybe I could pick
a better prior for the the slope that
that penalizes having a uh penalizes
getting better when you get farther away
but it turns out that this
that those disappear really quickly once
you condition
so this is our prior predictive check
we can move around to fitting the model
um if you see me in the hallway
afterwards this is where uh this is
where my happy place is I'm not going to
focus on what's actually going on here
today this is why we are using jacks or
some sort of Auto differentiation
Library so a library that knows how to
compute derivatives because you can do a
much better job of fitting a model once
you have derivatives
um tfp ships with a function called
window adaptive nuts that runs a
wonderful gradient-based sampler it'll
do a good job drawing samples from your
model
I should notice note that right here is
when we first introduce our we actually
condition right here so we conditioned
and say the number of successes we had
was actually the number of successes
from the data
boy great question
uh Jax is a uh you should think of Jax
as like uh numpy but it works on
accelerators and it has gradients
um so if you have a GPU and do you want
to compute gradients you can mostly
convert all your code instantly to Jax
could have used a slide or two on that
can you compare Jacks to Pi torch and or
the component of high torch that gives
you
subscribe tensor computation and
I'm one of the few people who haven't
used Pi torch yeah
so so all I can say is is that I know
many very happy pie torch users and very
happy Jax users I guess has been
conceptually like are they similar yes
so I think my my general View and this
is speaking as a pie torch note novice
is that uh I would think these as
lighter weight Frameworks than say
tensorflow
um but both of them feel a lot like
you're using numpy
um plus you have these extra functions
that give you uh to give you these
things like gradients or or vectorizing
your computation
please
that's also a great question
um so so the the question asked was why
are we using why are we going right to
Bayesian models here I'm going to assume
that we care deeply in this case about
the uncertainty around our estimates as
well and it turns out with some of these
uh with at least this first model you
could compute that by hand
um if you do enough math but we're about
to move to a second model where you
wouldn't be able to to get the
uncertainty on your estimates
um this this case study
um was originally I think from Andrew
Gelman I've ported it to Pine C
intensible probability and one of the
things I did with the uncertainty was
eventually you can get like how many
putts will it take if you start from 20
feet away
because because you'll actually get
estimates on how far away you'll be
after one Putt and two putts and so on
and so you can like play things forward
which would be very hard to do with a
the curfew
any other
these are wonderful questions
perfect
so we fit a model we move around to
validating our computation here I'm
passing off to this Library called RVs
RVs is a library designed to validate
and uh and plot computations from
Bayesian libraries
and
one thing it gives you is summary and I
just want to tell you how to read this
summary because it looks a little
intimidating the first number I look at
is this R hat column
um our hat uh should be around one if
it's bigger than like 1.05 you you might
have had some problems uh and you might
want to go back and look
all of these are necessary but not
sufficient so if our hat is one it means
you might have done a good job fitting
it doesn't tell you you definitely did
but if our head is Big it says you did
not do a good job fitting
the other number to look at is this
effective sample size ESS so ESS bulk
gives you
well let's step back mcmc gives you uh
correlated samples so each draw will be
correlated with the draw before it
correlated samples are not as good at
Computing like say uncertainty as
independent samples and ESS you can
think of as the number of independent
samples that you've got
um so in this model I actually I ended
up drawing four thousand
getting 4 000 points but that's only
worth 2200
uh independent draws
so that's how you might think about the
CSS and that's really helpful if you are
Computing uncertainty and if you want to
know like something about your Tails how
well you can control the standard
deviation on your estimates
but like really if you're
if you're doing this usually like 100 is
probably good enough you know your error
goes down as the square root of the
number of independent draws you have so
2200 is quite good and I probably won't
notice that I did not have independent
draws
great now we can evaluate and use our
model so this is this is sort of the
curve fitting and and we did a lot more
we we burned a lot more CPU time than we
would have if we had just optimized for
this curve
um but you can actually see there are
100 curves drawn here the one in bold
orange is the mean of all my draws but
all the the little shaded ones that you
can barely see are all the other places
where uh the mean probability of going
in are plotted
um so this did an okay job it didn't fit
well here it kind of misses this
um
uh the other thing that's funny and the
other way you might evaluate this model
is you can just plug in points
um
so right here I'm calculating what's the
chance of making a putt from 50 feet
away
uh
and I think I think e to the minus five
is like out of ten thousand so it's like
2.7 out of 10 000 times it might be 27
or 10 000.
um division is very hard
um so that seems like a pretty low
chance uh you might not know much about
golf we can really quickly check with a
Google search how often people make a
50-foot putt uh it looks like it's not
like two out of ten thousand rare so
maybe this model is a little bit like
underconfident in the ability of
professional golfers especially outside
of the this
place where we trained it right I think
we all know
it's it's common to know that you you
might not want to run your model well
outside of where your training data was
that's what I'm doing here you know 20
feet was the longest Putt in the
training data and I'm asking about 15
feet so like maybe it's reasonable that
it's making wild assumptions about that
but
um but this is how we evaluate our model
if this is what we cared about we might
want to go back and modify our model
so
if you get bored probability that goes
in is a really fun geometry problem that
you can work on for the rest of the talk
and so the way we're going to think
about this is when you want to make a
putt
you're standing say 10 feet away you're
putting a ball uh and and you know which
direction to aim and maybe you you can't
hit it exactly in the right direction
right so you might be off by a couple
percents of a Radian
um and if you're off by too many percent
of radiant it'll Miss
um so that's going to be our new model
uh and you can write the probability
that goes in given the error in your
aiming giving how far away you are
distances here is is plural because I'm
expecting a vector to come in
but once we have that function we can go
and plug that back into a probabilistic
model we now have just a one
I highlight this yeah now we just have a
one parameter model but then I'm adding
a deterministic node here so that's the
probability that goes in and I'm passing
in our angle error to that along with
the actual distances from our data set
and what we're going to get is again a
binomial uh distribution but now I'm
passing in the probabilities instead of
the logits that I did last time
so we modified our model
I'm going to do a more interesting prior
predictive check this time where I
sample from the prior and I see where
the prior suggests we we actually putted
the ball so green is where we start red
is where we're aiming and our prior says
that maybe a professional golfer when
they're starting here sometimes hits it
over here
that's not that reasonable some other
things that are weird about this is that
if if they're off by a big enough angle
they might go all the way around to here
which puts like a little too much
density here compared to what I wanted
because you can get there in two
different ways you can miss to the left
or way to the right
um so there's there's some funny things
about this prior but it turns out the
professional golfers don't actually hit
it this way that often
um so you don't have to worry about that
you can fit the model again
you can go back and compute your uh your
R hat again so that our hat is really
good the the effective sample size is
even higher so I got even more effective
independent samples
another diagnostic Europe might run as a
trace plot
the trace plot on the left this gives
you a histogram a density plot of your
draws for that parameter and on the
right it's sort of a Time series of
those draws
um I've showed this because this is just
like a really pretty uh like set of
histograms uh so if you if you sort of
think about what's going on here
um this blue one is the chance of making
it from two feet away along with our
error on that estimate this is from
three feet four feet five feet and so on
so it's uh you move sort of from the
right to the left because there's high
probability lower probability
uh the black tick marks on the bottom
are where mcmc encountered this
technical problem with its numerical
integration
um seeing those does mean that you you
ought to mess with your uh
sampling method a little bit or mess
with your model a little bit to make it
easier to sample from
um so so those those should make us
worried despite seeing a really good R
hat and a really good number of
effective samples
and this is why we check all of our
Diagnostics
but here's another diagnostic
um and we can keep on going like this um
so so one thing about our previous model
was that we assumed that the
professional golfers might not be able
to aim the ball in the correct direction
but they would hit it the exact right
distance every time so one other way to
change it is to say hey they they hit it
about the right distance but there's
some normal error on how far they hit it
so if we again draw from our prior
predictive check we'll get this we could
keep going around fitting the model this
is actually the model that uh
the in the case study that that Gelman
wrote he ends up on and so you can see
this one and the results they fit this
uh this data set as well as a
bigger more modern data set quite well
great so any questions on the sort of
the Bayesian workflow that we just went
over I'm now going to go start talking
about actual libraries and and uh
places that aren't that model is there a
value in narrowing the prior down to
sort of in the direction of the cup
yeah so so the the question was is there
value in narrowing the the uh the
probability
um
you can get into like these huge
arguments about how much priors are
putting a finger on the scale versus not
I think
um I think most successful and pragmatic
Bayesian practitioners try to use a
weakly informative prior
um so I think it wouldn't
uh I would not raise an eye if you were
putting very little probability on it
going behind you I would raise an eye if
you said that there are zero probability
of hitting it back there
but if there's like exponentially little
probability then that's that's fine
um because because you it would need to
be extraordinary evidence to convince
you that sometimes professional Putters
like
when they intended it forward
but yeah the other case in which you
might need to do that is if you do see
integration errors like that sometimes
the model those come from curvature in
the posterior and sometimes that
curvature gets smoothed out if you have
a little bit more constraining of priors
so there can also be technical reasons
to do that and then you can argue over
whether
you should actually be changing your
model because your sampler is not good
enough
yeah like like I said I'm uh perhaps too
enthusiastic about the sampling part of
this
so any other questions about the sort of
the case study and stepping through the
workflow
yeah so that uh
the
I'll explain this yeah so so the
algorithm that we're using um is an mcmc
algorithm mcmc proposes a new spot and
if it's at a high spot of higher
probability it'll always accept and if
it's lower probability it'll sometimes
accept with the right ratio and then it
because the math it works out these
greeting based Samplers they actually do
this numerical integration internally
and if the integration was done
perfectly you would always accept
the integration isn't always done
perfectly and and the worse you do it
the faster you'll go so we try to do it
as bad as possible without wasting
computation
and so sometimes you break the
integrator and it runs off towards
infinity
and one way that happens is just you're
a little bit greedy another way that
happens is that there's a region of high
curvature that you can never get to with
your integrator
and so the fact that you could never get
there means that you'll never explore
part of your posterior and you no longer
have uh you will no longer compute good
expectations
that's
I don't know like half a semester of uh
like Bayesian computation
any other
again thanks so much for all the
questions this is uh very good
um so the next thing I want to talk
about is an ecosystem for probabilistic
programming I've got a bunch of logos
down here including the new Pine C logo
that does not include a three on it
uh this is uh this is exoplanet
um so Dan Foreman Mackie is an
astronomer down at the flat iron
Institute
um MC I believe has the most citations
of any of these I think it even beats
Stan
um and I'll show some things about that
it doesn't beat tensorflow itself but it
does be tensorflow probability
um but exoplanet is a newer uh newer
version of this MC Library
um and any you know as as with the
keynote anything we can do in open
source to help the astrophysicists we
will do because it's so cool
okay so this talk was was largely uh
inspired by a blog post I wrote
four or five years ago that implemented
this linear model in five different
probabilistic programming languages
um so I generate some data here using
numpy
um anything with an underscore after it
is hidden
um and so I just wrote down models that
tried to infer what the weights are and
what the noise is and here's just our
simulated data
um and in in many ways this is a
I sort of want to go through
some of those implementations and show
you what sort of the state of play was
five years ago and compare that to what
the state of play is today
um so this is Stan
um Stan is its own programming language
um it started with uh Andrew gelman's
group over in Colombia
um it's uh num Focus supported it's
fantastic I won't say anything bad about
Stan ever
um everyone tries to be like Stan um we
should all try to be like Stan
uh so this is this is what the the model
looks like in Stan if you're using r or
python there are good bindings
um to use there command stand is great
um and and this will run really fast
um this is not using Jacks this is using
its own auditif
um
uh this was Prime C3 this will actually
also run on Pine C version four
uh this is a this is a library that I've
helped contribute to quite a bit
um I like how expressive it is it's
python native it used to run on thiano
now it runs on a fork of thiano called
asara
uh and it's it's pretty clear I think
it's pretty clear what's going on here
but you know again we're having a code
bath so we're just looking at how these
are written down
um this is MC I always feel obliged to
show this because again it's it's so
well cited in the astrophysics Community
um they take a different tact where
they're not thinking about their models
in terms of dags directed acyclic graphs
um they're thinking in terms of a prior
and a likelihood I'm always just uh
shocked when I go to when I talk to
astrophysicists because you know you
write down you write down these little
models in Pine C and they're like well
why don't you just write down the joint
density instead and they would prefer
doing this I prefer doing the other
um but but so there's the log likelihood
um so we if if you're sharp on like what
normal uh distributions what the
probability of a normal distribution is
that's the log probability of a normal
um and then we we do some more work we
use uh scipy.stats st.multivariate
normal to do some things
um but then we'll we'll run a sampler
the sampler they use is not very good
um and M uh exoplanet is an attempt to
sort of move uh more astrophysicists
into using gradient-based samplers
it's again I'd be happy to talk about
the sampler that they use and what it's
uh drawbacks might be
so this was before and in terms of the
Bayesian workflow four or five years ago
each of these libraries tried to own the
entire graph so if you're missing one of
these or if one of your libraries did
not do one of these very well for
example stand in Python did not have
very good uh
computation validation or visualizations
and so what happened was a few years ago
we started this project our views which
is also num Focus supported and RVs
tries to take away some of these nodes
from the libraries and any of these all
these libraries work with RVs so you can
go and do your all this model work
anything inside the blue circle you can
run in the framework of your choice pass
it over to RVs and then get the data
back and and keep working on this
Bayesian workflow
um that was really successful I think
that really helped uh help the Bayesian
ecosystem it helped people uh centralize
on a couple you know we all agree on
which algorithms we're using to compute
our hat and people are doing very active
research on on how to like compute that
better
um so this was really successful
and now in Jax I think the way the
ecosystem is going is splitting this out
as well so writing down your model
can be done in one framework then fit in
your model and doing the actual Bayesian
computation can be done in another model
and then RVs is still standing on the
side and
you know doing what it does best
so what do I mean by this
through here so here are three libraries
distracts distracts numpyro and
tensorflow probability so these are all
their input Port statements uh
and here's how to initialize a
multivariate normal in each of the three
libraries
so we've got there's a mu and a sigma I
think that both of them are just a
vector of Link three
um
numpyro is a little bit funny here
because you just use a normal
distribution and you call it that two
event
uh the difference between batches and
events is uh if I didn't include this.2
event and I computed a the probability
of uh of some point using this normal
distribution I'd get three numbers back
but if I compute the probability of a
multivariate normal at a set of three
points I'd get one number back right
because multivariate normals uh are our
distribution over perhaps
three-dimensional things whereas normals
are just distributions over
one-dimensional things so calling dot
two event says hey don't don't interpret
this mu and the sigma as three different
normals and interpret them as one single
normal that is multivariate
but now I can do cool Jax tricks uh so I
can I can I have these three
distributions I can draw some samples
using say diss tracks and then I can
compute the log probability of them
using any of the three uh A3
distribution objects
um so I'm trading from one library to
these others
and it turns out that uh sampling normal
distributions is such a standard task
that uh
if you draw the samples from any of the
three libraries using the same Jax key
you'll actually get the exact same
samples which is not Behavior I would
rely on but it does happen
is there any Jacks in here yet
this is this all happens to be running
on Jax
so right now yeah so the question was is
there any Jackson here yet all of this
is is running on Jax
um one thing about Jax's uh the keys are
stateful or stateless
um so you do have to pass this is the
only sort of difference that you then
you might feel in a numpy ecosystem
um
and
the other difference that you'd have
which I have not highlighted yet is that
you could call gradient on each of the
log probabilities but there's nothing
else too special about it so far but
it's called running and Jacks almost
incidentally and that incidentally each
one was written on top of Jax
exactly
exactly yeah so this is this is
incidental that they're they're all
using and so they all have the same
array array libraries underpinning them
and that's that's important that they
know how to use their libraries this
would also actually play well on this
page at least with uh numpy objects so I
could also be using Scipio to very
normal seer
is that if I want another sample just
just like check simpler and then
oh my God I I'm so happy I did not I did
not invite him here and uh to ask these
questions so yeah um so what what can we
do next we can use blackjacks um this is
a fantastic Library
um that's that has composable uh pieces
for mcmc it doesn't Define its own
statistical distributions it just
focuses on sampling
um I really like the blackjacks project
I encourage everyone to check it out
um it it is batteries not included so
you do have to put together some things
I copied this right out of the readme
um so it is easy to put this together
it's easy as a copy paste
um and then you can call Window
adaptation I'm passing in here at
distracts log probability and this is
where I could not be using numpy
um so it requires that it's Jacks
internally in blackjacks they are using
uh Jack specific Machinery like gradient
and vmap which vectorizes things so I do
need this to be a a Jax
function
and then I get then I get my States out
it'll do a fine job sampling another
thing I could do is I could use
tensorflow probability tensorflow
probability takes a different approach
to building samplers
um
it's uh you you might think of it as an
onion so you start from the inside
here's the no u-turn sampler
um
and I pass I'm passing the numpyro log
probability I can pass any of these
three
um and then outside of that I put simple
step size adaptation that does some
tuning to make sure my sampler will be
more efficient and outside of that I put
sample chain that's going to go and run
this mcmc sampler for some number of
steps then outside of that I put jax.jit
that makes everything go fast if you're
using jacks
often you will write down your function
and then outside everything you'll call
jacks.jit and then call your function
once it is jitted and that'll make
everything go faster
so here
you're casting in an object written in a
library that's written on top of Jax
into some other Library called
blackjacks which offer Samplers yes and
then in the next slide you are taking
a thing that's written in real Jacks as
per the input statement presumably uh no
this this numpy arrow is written in
numpyro which is written on Jax okay so
this is another log problem written on
Jax
written
yeah
so so the thing the this this object
here can be any function written in Jax
that returns a log probability okay
and this one just happens to be from
dump pyro but you could take you could
take the numpyro one and then add
jax.1s of eight to it
um and then you get some new number and
that would also be a valid might be a
valid log probability
um so this this can be any function that
computes the log probability of points
um and you just have to have a valid
point to start it off on so that's this
current state mu
so so if you have a function that eats
mu and returns log probabilities and
it's written in Jacks that'll work here
that'll work in blackjacks and that'll
work in numpyro
yeah
um
since it's there and yeah and so the the
last one is numpyro and just the way
that numpyro is defined is organized so
I'm passing in this log probability it
turns out numpyro cares about uh
potential functions not log
probabilities uh potential function is
just negative log probabilities so I do
have to put that little negative sign
there
um but then I can put that together into
an mcmc kernel and called that run
um the reason I don't use jit on this or
on blackjacks is because they're built
into the libraries so the libraries
themselves just called jit
tensible probability doesn't do that for
technical reasons
is what makes Jacks go fast
it's weird that there's a button that
says would you like this to go fast and
it's like not automatically pressed your
functions there's there are certain like
if statements sometimes can't be used
inside a jit
um so it is doing a compilation step and
sometimes your compiler will break um
but it does make it significantly faster
uh so jit is item potent which is
Pleasant
um so I could get this and it would it
wouldn't do anything but um it wouldn't
it wouldn't hurt but it wouldn't help
yeah do you have like to speak
embarrassing me
between classics
uh
benchmarks for Bayesian models are
really hard
um I would expect uh I would expect that
they are comparable because they are
running comparable
um
algorithms
uh so if the the question is how does
Stan or one of these Samplers calling
into Jax how do they compare in terms of
speed
um
there's a lot of parallelization work
done for Stan
um but you can scale this up to say like
doing a thousand independent runs at the
same time on a GPU and that takes about
the same amount of time as doing one run
and that's that's pretty powerful
um to the point where we don't really
have diagnostics for handling a thousand
chains there's some interesting Papers
written this year on doing that but but
yeah so I think
in terms of racing for one chain uh I
would expect that they're similar or
even the sand might be somewhat faster
for some models and I think Jax would be
faster for some models if you're doing
really really big Matrix multiplies um
uh Jax might help with their GPS
yeah so
so is the question about like yeah like
I guess
yeah yeah okay that's that's interesting
yeah so so why why does anyone else
bother if uh if Stan is great
um yeah that's a that's a great question
so it is useful
um to use Python if if you're in Python
um Stan is
tough to install
um and and I mean like as as with all
open source sometimes you have a niche
and you would have taken different uh
design considerations
um
you know certainly uh
certainly if you happen to work at a
company that has a lot of models already
written in Jax and you want to introduce
some sort of Bayesian uh flavor to
things it would be easier if you had
some jack samplers
perfect and I think
uh I think I'm just about done as well
yeah so the last sampler I want to show
is Pine c um this is only on version
four
um recently released
um so this is I'm rewriting the model
here as uh just passing this mu and this
Sigma
um and it has built in this uh sampling
Jacks module and so you can sample using
numpyro sample time C model using
numpyro you can also sample a pine C
model using blackjacks on both these
cases you'll get back Jax objects
or you can get the log probability right
from your model and then you can go and
do weird stuff to that log probability
so you can go and add more numbers or do
like some sort of wild simulation to it
from there
um so you can you can go from behind C2
Jacks you can't as far as I've done so
far you can't go from Jacks back into
behind C
a little bit too bad
um and the last thing which I'm not
going to focus on too much is like once
you have this jacksonified log
probability from PI MC or something from
diss tracks or something from whichever
Library you have you can go and use the
rest of the Jax ecosystem as well this
is optex which is just an optimization
library and so you can go and use atom
and optimize the log probability and
this is just finding this maximum
posteriori estimate which people often
care about doing this will work just
fine
yeah have two minutes for questions
two more minutes for questions
great and yeah and I'll just say these
are these are these integration paths
that I was taught earlier that can go
terribly wrong and this is just three
random ones running around so it's just
a pretty thing to watch if uh if we
didn't have questions so you all had
great questions hold on
I see a possible thinking about it no
what would it look like
terribly wrong
oh and just take off
um
no it would
yeah it should have to Infinity I think
the the bounds on this are like five or
something and it would be at like 40 000
after one step yeah
yeah you showed like a lot of software
energy is there like a place to
recommend like starting
um
yeah I mean I still like starting with
pine c as I'm I'll share also the the
collab that that runs all this and so
like also you might just if any of that
code struck you as like oh that's
Pleasant that looks fun
um you might try that as well
anything else or else I'll be around in
hallways and and always happy to chat
about this stuff it will
can you tell us who wrote Jax and what
role and the system Jax
yeah so Jack's uh
Jax is a Google project
um and I am I am I do work for Google
um so I'm trying to sell it to you for
the price of free
um but it the the same people who wrote
autograd which is an older Library it
wrote Jax
um so it feels very similar to autograd
if you've ever used that
um I find both of them very pleasant
they're both sort of functional
libraries so they transform functions
into other functions
um so if if people are into functional
programming they'll they'll enjoy jacks
um but Matt I you know I think like Matt
Johnson Dougal McLaren are some
gosh I'm on video and right now my
colleagues are going to be upset that I
didn't acknowledge them by name um
there's a big team that's uh working on
it yeah
and they said sorry we don't support
Windows
you know
has that
I think Jax does work on Windows now
um
yeah yeah wild wild asking about the
Google product supporting windows at
Microsoft
but so I don't know the the real answer
that question but yeah I'm sure there
are issues on GitHub
[Applause]